I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
Mr wankara can say you're a man a great
engineering what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like it dark white nutty absolutely
insane many people have come here to
sell chocolate they've all been crushed
by the chocolate cartel you can't get a
shock without selling chocolate and you
can't sell chocolate without a shop
no daydreaming what are we gonna do
Willie
huh
[Music]
thanks on paper uh-huh
I know things haven't been easy for you
they're gonna get better you promise
a pinky promise that's the most solemn
vow there is where do we start
where is this it's just cool what's
happening oh that's a chocolate that
makes it Fly let's find out shall we
who's forever job
nothing to see here just a small group
of people defying the laws of gravity
ladies and gentlemen of the gallery
Gourmet
my name is Willy Wonka
pretty sure I've gained about 150 pounds
in the last two weeks you could change
her life Mr organ change all their lives
every good thing in this world started
with a dream
so you hold on to yours
there we go Mama
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop the world has
ever seen
so you're the funny little man who's
been following me I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
foreign
oh I don't think I want to hear that too
late I'm stuck at dancing now once we've
started We Can't Stop
[Music]